we have a guest here so we're gonna put
this on cuz I still don't believe that
he's coming you think they're tracking
us so I'm gonna pull the blind focus
here's my plan if it's not him at least
we'll be like ah we try but if it is him
imma go nuts okay blind folding yeah I'm
gonna blindfold but I still need to look
at this it's gonna mess up my makeup
woodie's we have to deal with it damn I
would now like to introduce possibly it
could also be a PA I'm listening gonna
be Elba a Golden Globe winner the man is
the biggest baller on television in
media in music
American Gangster he was on the office
detective John Luther man wins a Golden
Globe on Luther which is awesome - he's
now office yes he was in the office
Nelson Mandela money go on Netflix and
watch beasts of no nation cuz it's
really I think it's we didn't really
believe you were gonna be here yeah so
they were gonna like bring somebody else
in in your place in case welcome thanks
man thanks you're here so I want to get
the reason you're here right away I
watched your commercial Tom Clint dude
it was awesome what was it like to make
it and and tell everybody about what
you're doing everything special
commercial we went to Prague to shoot at
Prague the real sexy city in my city or
we went to this studio there and made
this director killed it I mean it's a
very visceral you know campaign yes I'm
not in the game just to clear that up
BAM so I've been the commercial as a
curator of what you can expect from the
game yeah right you do that a lot you
did that for the NBA all-star game
you're great at setting things up so
it's no it's Rainbow six no NBA all-star
didn't do that I didn't do that I didn't
do that game I do no not the game the
actually actually because your voice man
you're like listen that's a good look at
our man style in here I mean got the
hoodie of the fashion faux-pas pants
with a little Bernard
we are we yeah we do a little bit big so
he wanted to make sure you lift well I I
know I just when I looked you up you
last night of course I saw some pictures
online as I come in he looks taller than
I'm not disrespecting most actors are
usually sure sure yeah and then of
course you're in good shape seeing you
in other movies and everything what do
you do they'd kind of stay in shape you
know I'm a kickboxer okay so I fight
train when I can right it's useful -
yeah it's really so just in case
somebody tries to steal your hot dog but
no like like keeping it you know being
an actor in china stage stay in the
shapes a bit of challenging the long
hours in ER but it's really important
for me you know a stanchion signed and
everything it's good get to be a shape
yeah what's it like to be the third most
attractive man on camera right now right
now struggling because normally I got a
lot of heat but the heats going that way
like I sweat when the guest comes that's
a tough I know you're a big Arsenal fan
your big gunner look man and a fella
zing is an England all the time mm-hmm
one do you think that England would
support an NFL team and I'm curious how
do Premier League fans compare with NFL
fans from what you play well it's an NFL
sells out every time it comes to England
you know the Wembley Arena and I think
they did a big deal with Tottenham
Stadium yes so to 2018 or something
they're gonna be brilliant FL games
there and every time you know people
people in England really really love NFL
comparatively know like munna fans with
rude boys you know I mean a lot but rude
boys were very sort of odd and if I was
a little bit more polite right you know
enjoy the sportsmanship right
Arsenal we know we're going for the
jugular cam you know to kill we want we
want goals we want our players to be
really good and we're very vocal about
that we have an Arsenal fan in the
office and he was a legit gunner Carlos
the stories that Carlos tells yeah I go
man FL fans do not understand right the
craziness over the right it's another
world I just got to Highbury man
Highbury was the first stadium now we're
Emirates Stadium but Highbury was a
really small intimate stadium was one of
the smallest stadiums
- because it was just compact and
beautiful right the energy in that
stadium inaudible my school stadiums I
like that the best
all right another question I honestly
didn't know you were English until last
night oh yeah I don't know even the wire
and of course I saw you an American
gangster and I was like man the accent
then I read or I see that you maybe
learned in a Brooklyn barbershop they
had the American a yeah but how do you
work on that and just toy with that all
the time alright when I was before the
wire I lived in America for in New York
for about four years
New York New Jersey in like one of my
tests my accent was to go to a barber
shop and just see if anyone could
recognize that I was right you know I'm
saying because barbershops you know just
like now yeah everyone's banner and you
better have an opinion yeah they'd be
louder than the next day
yes and they'll call you are for being
Fugazi exactly yeah especially and I
know nothing about football or baseball
so I'd have to talk about soccer in an
American accent man what do you talk
about it might watch that yeah I love
her stringer Bell
it literally I went after I watched the
wire and I bought books that the
producers had written because to me it
was like show in this culture of America
that hadn't been done correctly and
stringer was that character I was like
this is the and by the way you can curse
on our podcast I wrote one curse will
let you click yes so my thing is I saw
stringer Bell and I was like this is the
[ __ ] man like this dude is running a
business it's holding down we tell
visceral is that when you go out and
people do people just call you stringer
sometimes holding on real all the time
yeah I remember when I was coming out of
the stringer sort of era I'm sure a wife
I used to be really conscious about my
accent because people come up to me like
straight man was that matter how I met
he did you don't you know and it was I
had a little bit of an accent
phobia because I didn't want people to
think that I wasn't who I was on the TV
show yeah I know stringer Bell but yeah
people get attached to character so they
see me all the time is like sure I get a
lot of Luther now like that's right
you're right Nelson Mandela
you got some Nelson some no I don't get
Nelson every I was going to
but dude I mean you're all over the
place we love you here um if you could
do one thing for me the stringer Bell
voice I just want this so Tony Romo's
coming back he's a big guy in America
you place for the Cowboys if you could
just maybe look there and just go NFL
you thought you were safe
Tony Romo's back he's gonna make you in
trouble something I just do it in my own
accent because stringer bows dead ah yes
a you could do it in any accent around
you thought you were safe but Tony Ramos
is coming back you in trouble
there's more than one Tony Romo Oromos I
love it say action and the guys ready oh
no I would love to be a pundit would you
oh man I've got opinion and you know
people don't have opinions and they play
it safe it's not crazy because you know
people get you know like people a bit
shy but I think it's important to like
you know stated state where you on the
fence well jay-z I mean left go kind of
got me into this music of course one of
your passions I know you had a lot to do
with the American Gangster soundtrack
working with jay-z that experience what
was that like I mean were you did you
have the moment three like man I'm doing
music with jay-z yeah I mean jay-z I
never I actually did once at a club when
I was about 22 he's a really formidable
character lovely person raised like his
presence is in the room and you know
he's a genius obviously because he comes
up with you know all his thought
provoking you know right you know on
beats but we're of American Gangster I
send that to him I finished it and sent
it to him or her at least sent an email
back he goes I don't love it I you love
it I was like was there a pause between
the first and second time for him
obviously I worked if his wife Beyonce
write in a movie called obsessed yes
I'm sort of library man and looked me
right in the eyes man he goes young man
I like what you did he's really
something smoking J's a dude man I
respect me yeah you're I've seen a bunch
of pictures of you
at concerts and stuff your love for
music sometimes is that even bigger than
acting because I there's a true passion
there that I could see in your eyes when
you talk about it truth is man it's my
reset button you know when you're
playing you're an actor you play
different characters you know in the
Rainbow six commercial I'm playing a
character that you know doesn't exist
yes in the game you know I love to do
that but when you DJ it's you yeah I
just opened up from Adana
yeah no name drop yeah the same and it's
17,000 people behind this curtain I open
the Colonel's oh wow they're not here to
see me but when I play my music you know
I'm saying that's me I've got an hour
set I'm giving you me right I mean I'm
not acting not playing a character but
it really doesn't bigger ate me I'm
gonna lie I've been doing this since I
was four years old yeah I hear ya I mean
that's the way football was for me I
felt like I is three hours of me just
let losing time you say whatever I want
at you each question about football man
like you know as you grow as you grow
older do you feel the aches and pains of
all the knocks that you had it's almost
like a nightmare tell me what happened
on the field well I do yeah well so I'm
not gonna show my belly for the second
straight episode but so I lost my spleen
playing football yeah I almost died on
the field I lost nine pints of blood
I certainly do have issues a little bit
not know I only played for eight years
so I didn't get 15 years worth of
beating but like my father played
quarterback for the New York Giants here
for 15 years he has issues he's at three
back surgeries in the last four years
he's almost 60 but nonetheless yes
people of his generation certainly
banged up and yeah I do have things that
issue it's not affecting my quality of
life but all right but it's still I wake
up in the morning like oh man yeah that
was that hit or this is that hit I mean
I there's certain days like that I
played yeah I played rugby when I was a
kid right and I I pulled my thumb all
the way back here one time and the day
on the day I mean we just kept playing
yes right all right yeah I have a son I
would still put my son in and say go go
play sports yeah no is that is that
right I think it is I you know listen
there's gonna be risk in any sport I
mean the concussion rates for young kids
playing soccer the same as football
right here in America yeah because of
the heading the balls and doing that but
the things I learned from football I
think are the most
born they are any team sport you learn
the discipline how to work with others
the team yeah take constructive
criticism you know listening respect to
your coaches all that that's the thing I
think is the beauty of team sports at
least a lot of things I learned from
football I have a question for you
because it's a nice debate we have here
in the office right now I'm gonna give a
shout out to Kyle Johnson Ellis Williams
for having this discussion straight out
of Compton I guess that's a biopic but
it's not about it's more about like a
group and that was West Coast we were
having a debate when it comes to East
Coast rap what should be the first
biopic would you go the birth and
existence of bad boy or the birth and
existence of Rockefeller hmm which one
would you do for the East Coast hip hop
biopic bad boy would you but it wouldn't
be rap it would be you know it would be
around puff yeah right now - notorious
b.i.g yeah so POC because you're getting
that East Coast West Coast they do it
all the show because Rob Rockefeller is
is Jay yes he had great artists mentally
can all those underneath but the Empire
has really been around Jay
bad boy you know biggie Craig Mack you
know totally happens you know and they
were the first on the scene at least in
my opinion now the only thing I was
saying against that is you are still
getting Jay you're getting Jay biggie
and Busta at a cafeteria table which
would be a cool scene you're getting
Kanye you're getting a little bit of
young Beyonce to like you guys think
alike the hotter for me but bad boy
would be crazy - now the definitive film
would be Def Jam right period right Def
Jam pinnacle right there you got
everyone from the Beasties run the
monday MC yeah and the legacy of Def Jam
is incredible right that's the
definitive not East Coast hip hop film
why he went up to you athletes just
other athletes they respect so
actor/actress that comes out with a
movie no matter if you like the movie or
not you're like you know I want to see
their performance who who jumps out to
you that way
dr. day-lewis for me every single time
right real right walking penis every
single time ah Denzel never
ever felt yeah you know he's such a
dedicated actor I love him I have to say
I like Ben Stiller is that okay that's
cool I may be hated the music yeah he's
funny I love it right seems sincere and
genuine as I appreciate my uh you're
gonna hate us okay
really man yeah you're gonna hate us no
you won't hate us but we love you so
much who's coming up someone coming out
hey you are you're coming out yeah are
you haters out there that have a problem
you can't control this okay this man was
born for this everyone can I see the
control room we're popping it we are the
house you can't handle this and it puts
you in a situation we got the camera guy
Gabe holding it down man this is a
movement yeah I get it we all wanted we
were afraid you might like flip bad on
us everyone was like let's not show this
until the end of the interview okay okay
here we go ready yeah boom boom man I'm
gonna eat your cell but here's here's
here's what I saw him here's the truth
he was not Shirin when I watched that
Tom Clancy commercial there was one part
where you sat back while a guy was like
blowing through a door and I went that
is what it needs right now I went and
saw it and I'm it needs that element of
cool it needs that element of just style
and that's what I think you would
provide dude I think that your
trajectory has been incredible you were
born for this
no man I do I appreciate no you can't
comment on it cuz all that stuff but I
really believe that I can't count on it
because ultimately it's a rumor right
that's just taking off it's unbelievable
I keep saying you know it's a will of a
nation that people won there will happen
but it's Revere's you know I actually
think that bond probably should reinvent
itself and go younger
no no you're saying maybe not even you
you're absolutely I think the concept of
super spies is a little dated
right lambaste it forces you know you
know spies have taking up people don't
you know spying a tuxedo anymore you
know I mean I literally I think they're
having they should go younger and I
think they should go a lot more sort of
like savvy with what's really going on
in the world right right okay I respect
that though yeah you the man I respect
that but I love the t-shirts yeah show
me the guys in the back again yeah let's
hope you didn't take your teachers up oh
gosh she wants to see us together
dude you're the man again check out they
want to make sure you pitch it one more
time all right so check out Rainbow six
siege is a great game
if you're a gamer you're gonna love this
game is really ground breaking man oh
yeah I'm all I'm all for this be
abundant blues men like give us a hot
take right now about something in sports
that pisses you off okay so you know you
guys saw you know Jose Mourinho yes say
I know Chelsea fans are gonna hate me
when I give it to London I don't care
man ask those the only London team and
you know man
you know we just opened up a bleacher
report office in London so what's the
worst is gonna be like who are those two
crazy Americans talking about some busy
and MIDI drizelda that's gonna be the
best part of it that's good fun thank
you
well you're gonna good day man yesterday
out of a baby I can't believe we got him